well cosmetic surgeries on the rise
across the country especially among gen
Z and not all the procedures are the
traditional type if you can uh call any
cosmetic surgery traditional this new
generation is uh it's getting Innovative
often in the most grotesque ways
imaginable so for instance one of the
hotest procedures on the market is
called uh kto pigmentation which along
with being a great Scrabble word that I
think I pronounced correctly actually is
also a surgery to change the color of
your eyes New York Post reports quote
don't want to be a brown-eyed girl
anymore if you're not afraid of the
risks including go going blind iris
color changing surgery the latest
procedure to go viral online might be
for you the process known as KERO
pigmentation involves using a laser to
create a tunnel in superficial cornea in
order to place pigment but experts are
warning it could lead to many terrifying
conditions including blindness not to
mention it's not approved for cosmetic
use just last week the French company
new color experts in KERO pigmentation
shared footage of one patient who
changed her brown eyes to a Stark
vibrant blue in a clip scoring 16
million views on Tik Tok but for one
model it cost her her precious Vision oh
my eyes eyes naen Bruna traveled to
Columbia to change her Hazel orbs to a
bright gray undergoing a different
procedure that uses a silicone uh
implant only to lose 80% of her vision
in her right eye and 50% in her left
well that is surprising apparently if
you let someone burrow a tunnel into
your cornea and inject it with ink or I
guess an implant or whatever it was in
that case it might do some damage to
your eyes it turns out that
intentionally damaging your eyes will
result in damaged eyes who could have
known and by the way if you're wondering
what what the end result of this uh eye
surgery looks like well here it
[Music]
is
okay so you see there if you're uh if
you're trying to look like one of the
X-Men then this is the procedure for you
I guess which which maybe it probably
makes it sound cooler than it really is
in truth she just looks bizarre you know
like some kind of AI Recreation of
herself but this is the effect that most
cosmetic procedures have on people and
and and that's a problem because
cosmetic surgery as mentioned a moment
ago has never been more popular long
gone are the days when only aging upper
class 52-year-old women got work done
now everyone is doing it especially
young people plastic surgery procedures
increased by 20% from 2019 until now
according to plasticsurgery.org uh the
same Source tells us that the Gen Z
crowd accounted for nearly 40% of all
nose jobs in the previous year and 25%
of all cheek implants because cheek
implants are apparently a thing
Meanwhile my generation Millennials seem
to be particular fans of buck
augmentations and have accounted for
more than 40% of those his buttocks are
Sublime perhaps not surprisingly
liposuction is the most popular cosmetic
procedure of them all right right ahead
of breast implants and all of these
surgeries are being performed um more
often and they're starting at younger
ages with profiling surveillance and
data harvesting there are lots of things
to not like about tech Giants but what
can you actually do about it when you
rely on so many of their products we
don't all have $44 billion to go buy up
Twitter and reform tech companies from
the inside the good news is you don't
need to be a billionaire to take a stand
for less than $7 per month you can join
me and fight back against big Tech by
using
expressvpn how do you think big tech
companies make all their money anyway
well they do it by tracking your
searches your video history everything
you click on and then selling your
personal data expressvpn helps you
anonymize much of your online presence
by hiding your IP address which is a
unique identifier that every device has
has it allows big Tech to match your
activity back to you that's why I use
express VPN on all my devices to make it
much more difficult for them to exploit
my data for their own profit and the
best part is how easy it is to use the
expressvpn app I just tap one button on
my phone or computer turn it on and it's
as simple as that so if you don't like
big Tech tracking you and selling your
personal data for profit it's time to
fight back get expressvpn right now to
protect your online freedom and privacy
and get three extra months free by using
my Link at expressvpn.com Walsh YT
that's expressvpn
/yt to learn more the New York Post
again reports as celebrities Scramble
for doses of weight loss Aid OIC gen Z
is booking cosmetic procedures more now
than ever in fact 75% of plastic
surgeons saw a spike in clients under 30
according to data release last week by
Thea American Academy of facial plastic
and reconstructive surgery which is a
consistently higher Plateau over the
five previous years border certified
plastic surgeon Dr Ashley Amalfi said
that she's seen an uptick and young
clientele at the quatal quatal quatal
quella center for plastic surgery in
Rochester New York and now about 1third
of her patients are gen Z quote I really
see that as sort of this extension of
the beauty Market she called the trend
great they are a population in general
who's just taking really good care of
themselves now I'm not sure that taking
good care of themselves is the first
attribute that I would associate with
genzi or any other current American
generation you know over half of genen Z
are obese first of all so it's hard to
say that they are particular adapt at
self-care and they may use the phrase
self-care and talk about it a lot and
they make Tik Tok videos about it but
the results tell us a different story
and of course plastic surgery is rarely
an example of taking care of yourself
now sure here and there you might find a
person who had a procedure done and they
actually do look better because of it I
mean that does happen I'm not denying
that there are people who have
deformities or other sorts of visible uh
physical afflictions Burns that sort of
thing where plastic surgery could truly
change their lives for the better but
those cases are likely in the minority
probably rather small minority and most
of these people especially the 26- year-
old women going to the surgeon for cheek
implants and Botox and lip fillers and
so on they wind up looking significantly
worse by the end of it because because
they look less human you're not quite uh
human how are you like that that woman's
eyes like that those those don't I don't
know what that looks like those are not
human eyes it doesn't look like a human
human's eye I don't know what that is it
looks artificial and that's the general
effect of so many of these procedures
they make you look less real less
authentic and looking less real and less
authentic automatically means that you
look worse because to look less human is
to look worse as a human because as it
turns out you as a human being are a
whole complete creature you are not a
potato head doll you cannot mix and
match your parts and reassemble yourself
however you choose well you can do that
thanks to the wonders of modern medicine
but everyone will be able to tell that
you've done it you know we'll look at
your reassembled face and think hm
something's a little bit off about that
it's not quite right so you may not like
your eyes or your lips or your nose or
whatever but those are your eyes and
your lips and your nose and if you go
and get different eyes lips or nose
they're not going to be yours anymore
your cheek implants may look like cheeks
but they probably won't look like your
cheeks it will appear as it is like
Parts have been artificially attached to
you or artificially inflated to resemble
a size and shape they were never meant
to be certainly the case for every lip
augmentation that's ever been done and
that's what makes plastic surgery so
cany you know the weird thing about it
is that like if I if I see you for the
first time and I never knew you before
never saw you before most of the time I
like anybody else will still be able to
tell if you had work done on your face
it'll be obvious that those artificial
or artificially accentuated features are
not your features which is kind of
interesting when you think about it
because I don't know you I've never seen
you
before but I know that how you look
right now is not how you really look
that's because the picture doesn't quite
make sense the features don't fit
together it does it doesn't match it's
not real there's something asymmetrical
and inauthentic and out out of balance
about it you don't look how you were
made to look and even people who don't
know how you were made to look can tell
but of course people don't believe that
they were made these days at all that's
part of the problem the reason uh
cosmetic surgery is as popular as it is
is exactly that many people think that
they basically materialized out of The
Ether for no reason and for no purpose
and now they are Gods over themselves
they are in charge of their own
self-creation they set to work then
rebuilding their own bodies and at the
end of the whole process if it ever does
end which often it doesn't they have
become some pale imitation of what they
were before some weird Picasso like
rendition of themselves which like any
remake is only very rarely an
improvement over the original and that
is why the plastic surgery craze is
today
[Music]
Cancer